[موسيقى]
لو موت ما حدش هيتفين والله احسن من
النهار
الاب الذي اثنى عمره يعملوه لبناء مستقبل
اولاده وبناته ليكافؤه باستخراج شهاده
وفاه له وهو على قيد الحياه والسبب هو
الطماع في الميراث
[موسيقى]
ايه اللي حصل
ابني
وانا كان عندي هو بالدنيا
[موسيقى]
كلموني وانا كنت بروح عندهم قالوا لي ان
ابوهم مات
حضرتك ما سالتهمش مات ازاي يعني اللي مات
ده مش له جثمان حتى
لان هم كانوا طلعوا له شويه وفاه احنا ما
نعرفش طلعوها ازاي
مصر
وما فيش حاجه قلت جواز السفر
يعني انا ما كنت اعرف ثلاثه ايام عنده ما
اعرفش
انت لما كنت مسافر ما كنتش بتتواصل معهم
فبعد كده اقول له يا ابني احنا معانا
محامي ومش عارف اطلعها لك
وما طلعتش وبعدين اي حاجه انت عايزها
نعملها انما شات هو فعلا يروح السينما
خالص
وعيالي شاهدوا ان انا مش هاقول الولد ده
عمي وده مش ابويا يعتبر فؤاد جايب واحد من
الشارع شبه يعني
الطب الشرعي سهل جدا يثبت ان انت ابوهم
حولهم بقى الطب
الشرعيش ثلاث مرات نروح نحضر ما بياخذوش
منه
لازم التحليل يكون الطرف الثاني موجود لما
الولد قال ده مش ابويا القاضي حولنا احنا
الاثنين طب بص احنا عملنا تحليل
[موسيقى]
بعد 12 يوم 12 يوم كانت جريئه
ثمان سنين انت ماشي معك شهاده
[موسيقى]